you've released a new instructional on
takedowns and standing skills for jiu
jitsu
just at a high level
using Nicholas as an example what are
some key ideas about takedowns
okay first whenever people talk about
standing position as you so they all say
oh I need to learn some takedowns but
it's never a question of just learning
the takedowns it's learning the
prerequisites to the takedowns the
takedowns are more or less like an
afterthought
um
you've got to begin with stance
motion the ability to engage in grip and
contact get your opponent out of balance
and then comes the takedowns
um the takedowns in Jiu Jitsu are mostly
divided into a lower body takedowns
tackles to the legs single legs Double
legs to a lesser degree high quality
and then upper body takedowns which are
mostly Judo derived
um
Nicholas had to start more or less at
the ground I didn't even know how to
come out and make grips or hold a stance
so he had to learn every element of it
and the fact he was able to do so in six
months was just incredible can you
comment on the
uh the upward posture that seems to work
for you just the matches in Jiu Jitsu
are much longer than the magazine
wrestling
um in addition there are many kinds of
submission threat which are not there in
wrestling so The Stance has to be
significantly changed in wrestling they
favor generally a very low Crouch
because the vast majority of attacks are
tackles to the legs so anyone who stands
upright and wrestling tends to get
heavily punished by being taken down
immediately with a leg tackle
um in Jiu Jitsu the matches are so much
longer it would be difficult in a
40-minute match for example to maintain
a bent over a crowd should be exhausted
uh there's also problems associated with
submission holes there are many forms of
submission hold Guillotines tasks Etc
where if your head comes down too low
you become a little vulnerable to this
and so the the stances in uh Jiu Jitsu
competition tend to be much more upright
more like Judo and Greco so right off
the bat you see The Stance is different
the motion tends to be much slower and
more evenly paced because you've got to
be able to do this for long periods of
time so the the number of fakes per
minute the number of shots attempted to
per minute is usually much lower
um
so these are obvious differences
uh the biggest difference however has
nothing to do with that it has to do
with tactics in jiu jitsu
these scores
will be judged by what happens after the
takedown
in the case of ADCC
you can take someone down
in ways that would score in both
wrestling and Judo and possibly even win
the match in the case of Judah
and it would score zero in ADCC because
of the the nature of the rules
the whole idea of ADCC scoring is to
demonstrate control after the takedown
it's what happens in the critical three
seconds after the takedown that creates
the score in Judo and in wrestling
the emphasis is based on the takedown
itself in Jiu Jitsu the emphasis is
placed on the aftermath of the takedown
that's where the score is allocated
and that can be a period of up to three
seconds now three seconds doesn't sound
like much but in a scramble after I take
down three seconds is a [ __ ] eternity
it goes on forever and so you will see
many examples of takedowns that as I
said would score very well and and Judo
and wrestling but don't score at all on
80cc
and so the whole skill becomes packaging
the standing position in terms of the
takedowns themselves but in particular
preparing the athletes for that critical
three seconds after the takedown that's
why many people who have very fine
wrestlers struggle in ADCC they take
people down by wrestling metric all the
time but don't score under ADCC rules